hey welcome to every damn day we're
gonna be dedicating our entire episode
to talking about how Banksy just redid
the American flag guys what do we think
okay I guess those are all of our
thoughts so the show is done now like
comment and subscribe
guys what the hell this is a discussion
show you need opinions and personality
and a passion for the issues not in an
annoying way like Ryan obviously but can
we pull something together like 60
minutes but for me you all need to
develop personalities because you are
boring and unrelatable to do that why
don't we brainstorm some character
traits for each of you that we can use
to write fun new segments sound good I
have one Ryan you resemble a sickly bird
that turned into a sicker human so what
if we did a segment called Ryan eats
worms on camera wow that's really great
how about Natasha hmm what if we did
something about how Natasha has become a
really good actor because she has no
personality of her own and is hiding the
fact that she's a sociopath you guys
crack me up me normal this is great
really good stuff let's keep it going
how about Chris well Chris is a loser
conspiracy theorist who watches
Illuminati listicles on YouTube so no I
don't we're watching a video called 10
reasons Stewart little as Illuminati
how many behind those closed down and
Hannah you were kind of mean to me from
the start and everyone in the office
thinks you're so let's just do a segment
about that ouch that stings but without
honesty there's a personal growth
hey what's up guys it's me Roy Wood jr.
just wanted to pop in real quick let you
know that you're all deeply flawed
except for Joey pizza here he's my best
friend thanks right we're doing here see
you lunch I'm buying
and my character trait is I'm kind of a
funny one the group so let's just roll
with that sounds good and truthful in
fact I just got an email from the exec
that said Jordan is getting his own show
[Music]
then we fade out the end ooh really
great table are you guys like Bravo
you wrote a script it ends with you
getting your own show you really think
you're the funny one yeah all of your
character traits you wrote were just
criticisms of everyone else that's not
my fault I just couldn't think of
anything negative about myself
I'm good idea why don't we list a few of
Jordans traits
well you don't take criticism well and
you get really defensive that's not true
you bitch your mustache like 15 ants
battle your lip you dress like a mr.
Rogers that no one would warn and mr.
Rogers is my taxidermist I bet you can
only get your girlfriend what with your
tears who told you that
I don't know you Jordan I think you're
not my friend okay
great work lots of good ideas I guess
they're not gonna use my script I will
they
[Music]
you